In the last video, we visualized
an ethane molecule
with a Newman Projection.
What I want to do in this video
is show that you can
really visualize longer chains,
or even, we'll see in
future videos, even cyclical,
ring-based carbon molecules
with Newman Projections
as well.
And I guess the next most
complex molecule to study
would be butane.
We could do propane, but butane
will be interesting.
This was ethane right here,
butane will have four carbons.
And if I were to draw it in
kind of a ball and stick
model, it would look like
something like this.
So this would be one
carbon right there.
Then you would have another
carbon right over there, and
another carbon right
over there.
And then you'd have your
fourth carbon.
And then your hydrogens.
You would have a hydrogen coming
out like this, like
that, and then up like that.
This guy would have two
hydrogens that would
stick out like that.
This guy would have
two hydrogens that
stick out like that.
And then finally this guy will
also have three hydrogens, the
ch3, just like that.
Now, if we try to draw a Newman
Projection, here's
like, well, what do you consider
the front, or the
back, carbon in all of that.
And you actually can pick.
And what's interesting in a
butane molecule is, if you
pick this guy, so this is a one,
two, three, four carbon,
if you pick the two carbon as
our front, and our three
carbon as our back, and then we
viewed this carbon, the ch3
as kind of one of the add-ons
on to that carbon, you can
then do a Newman Projection.
So let's try to do this.
So this'll be the front one.
So we'll put this carbon in the
front, and we'll put this
carbon over here, we'll
put this carbon
over here in the back.
And before I even draw the
Newman Projection, let me
redraw this.
But I'm just going to draw
this, instead of with the
hydrogens, the bonds, explicitly
defined, I'm just
going to call this a ch3.
So let me redraw this.
So I'll do this in orange.
So you have this carbon.
I'll do this as kind of as a
modified ball and stick.
So that carbon, it has a
hydrogen, it has that hydrogen
and that hydrogen.
And instead of drawing this out,
I'm going to just draw
this whole thing right here and
I'll do it in, I'll do it
in magenta.
I'm going to draw this whole
thing as just a ch3.
So I'm going to draw this whole
So I'll draw it really big,
because it's not just one
atom, it's four atoms.
So this is our ch3.
And, well, to do ball and stick
everything really should
be a ball, so I'll draw a ball
there, a ball there.
So that's our carbon number two,
and then it has this bond
over here to this carbon
number three.
Which, when we do our
Newman Projection,
we'll put in the back.
So our carbon number
three is like that.
And then the carbon number
three, it has two hydrogens,
and then it has this.
You can kind of view it as this
methyl group attached to
it, if you want.
It has this ch3 attached
to it right there.
So I'll do the ch3, I'll do
it in this blue color.
And so we could draw
it like this.
So the ch3 is coming off-- so
I'll draw it really big
because it's not
just one atom.
So it's a ch3.
And then you have your two
hydrogens and they're-- sorry,
you have your two hydrogens
down here.
So let me be very clear here.
This hydrogen and that hydrogen,
that's that hydrogen
and that hydrogen, this thing
here is that thing there.
That big ball right there
is this whole ball.
And then let me find
a-- I'll do green.
This hydrogen and this hydrogen
is this hydrogen and
this hydrogen.
And when you look at it this
way, now you say, oh, now I
can see how I would draw
a Newman Projection.
I put this in the front,
that in the back.
I treat this whole part of
the molecule as just a
group, if you will.
It is a group.
So lets do the Newman
Projection here.
And we can think about where
it's most stable.
So the way I've drawn it right
here-- I'll do this as the
front, this carbon
two is going to
be the front molecule.
So you have the ch3
group going down.
And then you have these
two hydrogens,
hydrogen, and hydrogen.
That's the front.
And in the back you have
this blue one.
You can imagine in the front, if
we want to, maybe I'll do a
little small orange
thing to show this
is the orange carbon.
And then the blue carbon is
going to be in the back.
The blue carbon is in the back,
I'll draw it like this.
So that's my blue carbon.
The way we've done it here, we
have a ch3 pointing straight
up, and then we have
our two hydrogens.
Now, just like we talked about
in the first video on Newman
Projections, all of these groups
have-- these hydrogens
have electron clouds
around them.
This whole ch3 group has
a larger electron
cloud around it.
It's a carbon atom
plus hydrogens.
They all want to get away
from each other.
The ch3 is even a
bigger molecule.
So to some degree, it's going
to play a bigger role in
whether something has a higher
or lower potential energy or
whether it's wound or not.
So I guess the most obvious, or
maybe it's not obvious, but
the ch3 groups, since they
have the biggest electron
crowd, they're kind of crowding
the molecule.
This ch3 group and this ch3
group, they're going to want
to get as far away from each
other as possible.
So the way we did this, it
looks kind of like our
staggered conformation, but when
we're dealing with actual
methyl groups that are separated
as far as they can
from each other, we
call this the
anti-conformation right here.
And if we think about dihedral
angles between the two methyl
groups, the dihedral angle
here is 180 degrees.
180 degrees dihedral angle.
And this is the lowest
potential
energy or the most stable.
And if that confuses you when I
talk about lowest potential
energy, just think about it.
A rock on the ground has a lower
potential energy than a
rock that is 50 feet
in the air.
A rock on the ground is
also more stable.
It's less likely to
do something.
Something 50 feet in the air,
maybe if you nudge it a little
bit, it'll fall off the cliff
or wherever it is.
Or maybe it's already falling.
Who knows?
It's going to move when you have
higher potential energy.
Or it takes very little for
it to release energy.
But when you have
lower potential
energy, you're more stable.
So this is the most stable
conformation.
Now what are the other
situations you could do here?
Well, you could keep rotating
these-- let's say we rotated
the back carbon around
clockwise, what are the other
conformations we could get?
And so let me just draw the
front portion right here.
So you have your ch3, and then
you have your two hydrogens,
hydrogen, and hydrogen.
And let me copy and
paste this.
So there's two other real-- I
mean, there's everything in
between, but these are the ones
that are interesting.
Control copy, and then let me
copy it, copy, and then paste.
So I'll actually draw
three of these.
So then you have that.
Then let me paste it one more
time, and then you have that.
So obviously this would
be the front
carbon in every situation.
If I want I could make it a
little orange dot to show that
that's the front carbon.
And then let me draw
the back carbon.
I should've copied and
pasted this as well.
So you have your back carbon
in every situation.
Now, if we were to rotate this
character by 60 degrees--
actually if we were to rotate
the back by 60 degrees, what
would it look like?
Well, then we would have-- this
hydrogen would move up
there-- so then you would
have this hydrogen.
Actually if we were to move it
by 120 degrees, I should say.
This would be 60, and then
another 120 degrees.
So this hydrogen would
go up there.
This methyl group would now be
over here, and then this
hydrogen would go over here.
So we've just rotated to this
whole thing by 120 degrees.
Now, this conformation,
this was called the
anti-conformation.
It's the most stable because
the carbon-- the methyl
groups, are as far away from
each other as possible.
This right here is called
the Gauche conformation.
Let me do this in a different--
and you can view
this as the second
most stable.
At least the methyls
are staggered.
They're not directly
behind each other.
So here the methyls are
as far apart from
each other as possible.
If you look at the ball and
stick model, I actually drew
it in that conformation
right here.
They're as far apart
from each other.
If you were to flip this
molecule, if you were to flip
it, this methyl would get closer
to this methyl, and
their electron clouds would
start to crowd each other.
So in this situation this
is anti, most stable.
If you rotate a little bit
they'll get a little bit
closer but they'll still
be staggered.
You get the Gauche
conformation.
Now, if we rotate this, if we
rotate the back guy now 60
degrees clockwise, what's
going to happen?
Well, then you're going to have
an eclipsed conformation,
where the carbons are directly,
but where the methyl
groups are directly
behind each other.
And that's going to be your
least stable situation.
Right?
So you'd have this guy-- and
I'll draw it slightly-- so
you'd have this guy, ch3 there,
and then you would have
your hydrogens that are right
behind each other.
So a hydrogen and a hydrogen.
So in this situation where
eclipsed-- this is the least
stable, and also the most
potential energy.
And then if we were to go
another 60 degrees from this,
then we'd go to another
Gauche conformation.
If you rotate this another 60
degrees, then you'd have a ch3
here, and then you would have--
this hydrogen would be
up here, and then this
hydrogen here.
So this is staggered.
The methyl groups are, at least
they're not directly
behind each other, but they're
not as far as they could be if
we were to rotate another 120
degrees and get to the
anti-conformation.
So this one right here is also
a Gauche conformation.
So hopefully you understand
now that, you just have to
pick two carbons and then you
can, if there's, kind of, big
things attached to each of those
carbons, you can just
represent them as groups.
And when you do that-- you'd
use a Newman Projection for
any part of a molecule.
And when you do that, you can
start to think about how it
can rotate and what parts, or
what versions of it, will be--